Okay, so now that we've used beautiful soup to parse
this HTML, so that we can extract the values we
need to pass along in our post request, let's talk
about why these values are here. Well, as many websites
do, this particular data source uses these values to validate
each request that comes in. And if you're really interested
in specifically how, for example, View State is used, I'd
encourage you to look in the ASP documentation, to see
how those types of servers use that particular type of
value. Okay, so just in case it's not clear. What
we have to do first is submit an initial request
and then use the response that we get back, specifically the
values for view state and event validation in order to
make any subsequent poster request. So let's take a look
at the code. Now, one thing I want to point
out, something that I didn't mention last time is that here,
we've actually hard coded in the value for
airport less and carrier list. But of course, what
we'd be doing is actually looping through all possible
combinations of values in our airport list and carrier
list, from the data that we extracted using
this code. Okay, so in this code, we're making
an initial get request, parsing the response to get
the viewstate and eventvalidation, and then submitting a subsequent
post request. Let's run it! Okay. Here we're writing
this out to a file called virgin_and_logan_airport.html. Let's go
take a look at that file. Here it is.
And of course we're going to lose style information because
relative references will all be broken. we're not actually
pulling the CSS or java script files that are
referenced in this HTML file. So, instead of the
data that we wanted, instead we're getting a syntax error.
So we need to figure out what's going on there.